you
[Music]
all right now that we have a flavour of
the projects we did in the past year
let's move on to today's agenda we are
happy to have Samantha here who have
we've partnered with to plan out this
today's session as also tomorrow's
session so what they'll do is they'll
give us an overview of how social work
and AI can work together and more
specifically what's the plan for this
day how the NGOs will come in the next
session after lunch to present and what
expectations we should have from the
rest of this workshop good afternoon
everyone
we won't try to keep you away from lunch
for too long and make it brief so we are
part of samhitas social ventures I have
my two colleagues with me mister Siew
Yosh a missus or up who I will introduce
and they will be part of the
presentation so how you want to
structure the presentation today is you
want to talk about what we do as Amitha
a little bit and introduce ourselves
good talk about a little bit about us
good see us our technology platform the
need for AI in the social sector and
their problems as NGO see it because we
have been hearing from the technocrats
the technical perspectives so social
prospective a little bit and then how
the the breakout sessions and the
presentations will be formatted so so
submitters is a social consulting
organization so by social consulting I
mean we want to maximize the CSR profits
or the CSR impact so to say while
helping different type of stakeholders
so our stakeholders our CSR companies
government's NGOs social enterprises and
academic institutions so we were found
nine years now so we were founded
thousand nine and so far we have our
presence in 18 states by different
projects we execute and we have
leveraged so to say about for 460 CROs
of funds using a projects management and
research consultancy these are some of
our corporate lines who have we have
service in the past and are currently
working with and these are our partners
so their different foundation academic
institutions and we also working with a
billion B MGF
closely now on a backwash platform which
I'd be explaining in a bit a little bit
background on a leadership so Priya is a
CEO
she leads the operation as some with our
social ventures and is a economics and
public policy graduate from Yale
that's Madhu handles our operations and
all our project implementations with
different nonprofits and a look at her
board members and advisors so
essentially we we start with a CSR
consulting because along the NGO
partners who we all feel and rightly so
are very good in the fieldwork they know
what they want to do what has to be done
on the field but when it comes to
understanding technology or how to pitch
the ideas how to communicate what
problems they're solving they would
require some help
similarly on the other side the CSR
committee guys would have they have a
mandate of 2% to give to wife's in CSR
funds so usually when we meet clients a
lot of them might not nuance to what
exactly want to do with their funds so
they tell us that hey this is my budget
and my call calls areas are typically
education health and maybe in a woman
empowerment now you tell me what to do
so we probably have to draw an entire
map map for them plan out their strategy
what are the missions visions are and
how they can maximize the social return
so we work on csalt consulting the hand
in hand goes the project management the
research work we do to make that happen
and knowledge and capacity building on
both ends for the NGOs and for the CSR
clients we also have certain
collaborative platforms for specific
needs for example we had a collaboration
with gif where we worked to improve the
capacity building of social enterprises
to help them make better in size prepare
better pitches and match them the impact
investors in those fields the next one
was with the international financial
cooperation which works in clean energy
so the idea was that in India a lot of
rural villages don't have a supply of
electricity to find out alternative
electricity for supply method X solar
lanterns or you know
a battery-operated lights and make them
available to these people and the most
recently we are working on water
sanitation and hygiene with the BMG F so
this is a corporate platform and part of
this is a small ethnographic study and a
part of study we are doing in chandrapur
which is a district in Maharashtra so we
want to understand what are the problems
this face is because this is a highly
challenging district it has water
shortage it has large amounts of people
who difficut in the open so how we can
prevent that and we are calling on
innovators to work on the problems in
this district because we feel if we can
champion this district we can overcome
the most difficult mile then we can
apply the those solutions those
innovations to rest of Maharashtra so
that's our aim for this platform talking
about our own technology platforms and
lot of that there are technocrats are
here in this room so it's a good csr
platform where we bring in all the
stakeholders that is your NGO CSR
corporate people and know and knowledge
articles on one one platform - so to see
so we have about 3000 social
organizations registered on the platform
and we have leveraged 117 Crowe France
from that so we have essentially a
marketplace where NGOs put in their
projects and corporates put in their
funding requirements and we help match
them and also help them with different
products and to talk about more of the
platform there should be the most
correct person because he has that
technology team so I'll you know give my
mic to swash just to make a brief quick
introduction about the five NGOs you are
going to deal with in the problem areas
so they are working on problems areas
such as the mismatch between organ
donation and the organ demand so that is
one the next people are talking about
how we can improve outcomes for
agriculture farmers by improving the
crop yields once talks about neonatal
care and how we can improve and do a
prescriptive analysis of which babies
require more in medical intervention the
other one talks to talks about improving
education outcomes in schools and on
tobacco how to prevent a backward
so that's a quick overview of the
different problems you are going to see
in the next section over to mr. Siraj
thank you just before getting into the
what platform is then not getting you
the details of that any which base for
the time there are a couple of brochures
kept in there for those who are
interested I'm sure some of the NGOs
which we are working with they're aware
of any means but I think the purpose of
this platform is actually how we bring
in the technology further the need of
the ecosystem that's that so if you look
at at the center it's 117 that's
probably a tip of the ocean kind of a
drop of the ocean of the CSR funding
available in the in the country which is
coming in from law and for that we
require obviously a scale if you want to
scale up that not for me but for the
ecosystem then how you use the
technology in place and that's where the
good CSR came into an action so
basically we covered the whole life
cycle of a CSR I don't get into the
details of that but essentially it's
about why why somebody would like to do
those kind of interventions be it NGOs
or the social sector guys or the
cooperates how they want to do that or
before that what exactly they want to do
in all those things and then how they
want to do that now in each of these
places we look at the data is important
the things about how they can make use
of the data rightly how they are able to
use that data more effectively how they
are able to make that data transparently
and so on and so forth that's where the
technology we are trying to use it all
across it goes from the strat and if I
want to use the business kind of things
which in the CSR lifecycle way they look
at the strategy then the program design
actual implementation and then going
back to the actual impact analysis so if
I'm at back to the professor your thing
is in we start with actually a data
collection help them decide or tell them
this is where you can do it kind of not
predict predict policy but a little bit
of reception and what we see is as more
and more you saw 3,000 NGOs are already
engaged on the platform and also about
more than 50 kind of corporates but
if as I as and when more and more people
can start coming we will be able to make
more insightful and kind of
prescriptions and all those kind of
things and towards the end also doing
any impact analysis and monitoring and
reporting so that's that's where the
things fails but we are more like a
ecosystem builder kind of a thing and
hence we also beyond a technical
technologist part of it we do a lot of
outreach we get into these kind of
interventions because we look at it's
more collaboratively building in fact
the word some heeda is actually about
collective good so how we are doing it
together kind of thing and that that
brings us in this and in that terms I
think we keep on doing the of Survey
Research which is also goods goes into
knowledge part of it so this is one of
the recent survey that we did and we can
see it aligned with what we are trying
to do here as in what the corporates as
well as the NGOs are trying to look at
is obviously the fundraising then the
money money kind of resources their
effectiveness in terms of managing but
ultimately that use of technology
finding the right implementation
partners they are also on the top of the
things and so technology and in these
days we found yes AI is something which
is there in fact when we look also at
specifically to AI what kind of
expectations they are and these are
something and then we have fire NGOs
which are coming in but this is more
like the broader kind of an expectations
check I mean I just brought in here so
that it is in line with what we are
doing so we are good feel good about
that but maybe we can look at how we
take this forward and maybe keep
assessing are we actually meeting those
needs of a overall ecosystem now to that
end I think I will just leave this
further to Sarah who will talk more
about the breakout session and how the
day is planned forward thank you but
I'll just put it simply we what we've
done is we've partnered with NGOs not to
use PowerPoint to tell you the bleeding
obvious but to use PPT we've repurposed
the term PPT we've gone ahead and
understood the process of the NGO we
have understood the practices that have
been followed at the NGO space
especially from a date appellation
perspective especially from a validation
and a structuring perspective and then
finally it was looked at possible
technology solutions that can come
together so in the second half of the
day what we're trying to do is showcase
what's the problem statement and where
do we see a probable association of an
advanced technology like artificial
intelligence that can be loaded to
Marriot once this is presented so it's
more like a context setting we will then
kind of break out into brainstorming
sessions where we will have the domain
experts more from the MS RL lab who will
be then typed into these NGO tables who
will understand a little more in depth
of how they kind of look at data and
what is the availability of information
with them what are the challenges and
how they possibly want to use it come up
with possible use cases and solutions
which can then be presented in the first
half tomorrow right so that's like the
overall agenda and the framework